and so what I think is part of what's
what Pinker is documenting is as the
world gets safer we start getting used
to a low mayhem world yeah and these
these mayhem events stand out in our
minds and so it actually self
perpetuates where the safer it gets the
safer we need it to be because every
little thing that goes wrong stands out
in sharper relief ah that's a very
fascinating way of looking at it you
know what's interesting to me about
thinkers work is how much pushback he
gets and particularly about the world
being a safer place
like people want to keep putting
pointing towards violent episodes and
and and and racism and and crime and all
these different things different factors
as if it's some sort of evidence against
what he's saying when he's incorporating
that those current events into this
large database and he's saying yes it's
not that we don't live in Utopia
right but the world is vastly safer and
better now than it was a thousand years
ago or ten thousand years ago or even a
hundred years ago or even the thirty but
why is there so much pushback against it
well so the thing is that I think what's
going on and so people worry that it
doesn't look like a problem to be solved
anymore so when you want our kids we
both have lots of gay friends but we
didn't know it because they're not
telling anybody because someone's gonna
kick their ass if they knew that they
were gay right now yes gay people are
still discriminated against but it's so
much better than it was then what you
don't want to what I think people are
advocates don't want to say is well
there's no problem anymore because then
you can allow them to still run into
troubles in various circumstances even
though the trouble they run into today
is a thousand times less than the
trouble they ran into and very little
same thing holds for racism same thing
holds for sexes and they've all gotten
so much better but and sexual violence
is a perfect example you know if you
look at if you said this is in Pinker's
book if you said rape and homicide - you
call it both of them whatever level they
are in 1970 - a hundred and then you
track them through to the early 2000s
homicide is in the u.s. homicides
dropped down to like 50 rapes drop down
to like 25 but if you listen to women's
advocacy groups about campus sexual
assault and stuff you'd never know that
and the reason you wouldn't know it is
because they people worry well if you
think the problem is getting better on
its own then you won't keep doing
anything to help fix it and that's a
really unfortunate part of our psyche
because it makes people feel like
there's been no progress and when you
feel like there's no progress then you
think well maybe we need to completely
overturn the whole system and try
something new and that's of course the
point of Pinker's newest book
enlightenment now know things are going
freaking great turn it anarchy and all
those things are really bad ideas voting
for somebody like trumps a really bad
idea because things are actually running
along really nicely it's just that we
tend to forget it because every advocacy
group who's all worried about whatever
their particular issue is doesn't want
the word to get out that things are a
lot better than they used to be because
I think it's some fundamental level they
think well twenty five rapes here isn't
bad enough we better say that there's a
hundred you know I'm not saying they do
this consciously but of course twenty
five rapes here whatever the number is
is bad enough right it doesn't it
doesn't have to be the numbers that it
used to be when I was a child to be a
problem it all has to be is a number
above zero well there seems to the
people develop this vested interest in
promoting an idea and they want to
exaggerate that idea whatever it is
whether it's the idea that the world is
a safer place than it actually is or
whether it's the world is an idea of a
more danger more dangerous place than it
really is and for whatever reason once
we have it in our mind that this is the
thing we're married to we're married to
this concept of polyamorous life and
that this is a natural way to live or
that you know violence is inevitable and
then this is just a part of who we are
we tend to promote that and we tend to
have massive confirmation bias and it's
it's I think it's because we personally
associate ourselves with ideas we don't
look at ideas as being a thing like if
you think that something is one way and
then you're pointed towards evidence
that you're incorrect you feel like
personally you've been slighted or
you're being somehow somehow you're
being diminished by your lack of being
correct but your incorrect assumptions
and notions you're absolutely right that
is a weird and part of being a person
it's a very weird part of it being a
person it's the hardest part about being
a scientist because every good scientist
is wrong all the time I've been wrong
already on your show right and so it's
super hard to admit it because by human
nature you just want you want my
immediate reactions to fight against it
and not to say well hold on what's Jo
saying you know he's right I overstated
that let's back off right and so there's
this really lovely paper that came out
in 2011 by Mercy or
dan Sperber and what they argued is I
think they nailed it and they said
here's what it is our brain actually we
evolved our logical processing abilities
not to find out the truth of the world
but to convince you of my point of view
and so which does our logical abilities
evolved in service of persuasion not in
service of seeking out the truth because
of course if I can persuade you that the
world is the way it would in a way that
benefits bill that the world is you know
something about the way bill wants the
world to be is true then the world's
gonna be a little kinder to me it'll fit
my worldview and others will give me the
things I want and so I go through life
trying to persuade you of my worldview
rather than trying to find out what's
actually out there and so that's why you
think oh well smart people are gonna
fall for that no smart doesn't matter
how smart you are you you you're using
whatever brain power you have not to
define the truth but rather to find
evidence for your particular point of
view well I see I think it's also a
byproduct of ignorance because for the
longest time you could tell me something
and there was very little way that I
could find out whether or not you're
right or not I really couldn't know
you're correct unless I went and started
doing research and read some books and
whereas now I could just pull up my
phone and say hey Bill just said this is
that right and then the phone will go no
there's been a hundred different
Saturdays each other and you go oh look
[ __ ] yeah I got the stats that's
true and that definitely matters a lot
it's it's the this awesome
democratization of knowledge but if that
really were all that it was then
everybody would agree on their politics
everybody would agree that the fake news
was fake and the real news was real not
necessarily because this is a fairly
recent invention but what I'm getting at
is that I think that the ability to be
deceptive was perhaps there was an
evolutionary advantage oh absolutely
yeah so that's one of the very first
things that happens when you have theory
of mind because as soon as I realize the
contents of your mind differ from the
contents of my own I say oh I can plant
something in Joe's mind that'll help me
that ain't true but if he believes it
his life will be better for me right and
so as soon as kids learn theory of mind
at age four they start to lie and write
a theory of mind they tell the truth
when it's like um where are you you know
plane I think I'm right here dead you're
supposed to keep quiet but they can't
because they don't understand that you
don't know the same things they know
right
and they also understand that they could
perhaps change the way you feel about
them by manipulating the truth
manipulating information yeah it's
what's weird is having kids and seeing
kids that grow up and troubled homes one
one thing you see almost universally is
that those kids lie a lot you know
there's no choice condition right yeah
you're in a bad spot and like one of my
daughter's little friends is constantly
lying that you know she has a broken
home and the situation's not good and
it's just it's unfortunate but this
little kid is tormented because of it
she's always making stuff up and all the
other little girls roll their eyes and
they know she's a liar and it's it's sad
but the ability to be deceptive I feel
like that you know this is there's some
sort of idea that we cling to that if
you can deceive someone about certain
particular aspects of your mind or your
past or what you've what you've
accomplished or what you you're capable
of doing that you will have a better
place in the social chain no that's
absolutely right and so the way I think
about it is think about the difference
between cons specific conflicts
conflicts between members of the same
species and conflicts between predator
and prey so every time predator and prey
interact eventually one of them is gonna
die redditors gonna start off prey is
gonna get eaten right yeah but when
conspecifics remembers the same species
interact and we're competing over
something even if it's a very subtle
level of competition we don't want to
come to blows because if I'm trying to
size you up be it physical blows or
mental blows we there's suffering on e
both sides if we have to duke it out and
so I want to sell myself as being a
little more than I really am I want to
be bill plus 20% and you want to say
yourself as little more than you really
are because we know that we're not fully
gonna test each other because there's
negative consequences for testing and
whenever there's negative consequences
even for the winner for testing there's
a lot of posturing that's gonna go on
and that posturing is something that's
literally built into our psyche and we
go through life trying to self inflate
on average not a buddy does this but on
average trying to self inflate as much
as we can in order to gain the things in
life that we might not get if we were
brutally honest about what our
capabilities actually are that's so
fascinating that we cling to all these
ancient structures that are in place
the way we interact with each other and
how important it is like the social
exchanges that we have and that I think
this is one of the reasons why we cling
to ideas so much